though we want to congratulate you I
understand that you just signed with a
EF talent agency and I think the last
time we spoke to you was almost a year
ago yes a lots been happening I think
you've had numerous things happen can
you tell us how you signed with them and
what lessons did you learn in the
process that you can share with other
actors that's a very good question I've
been trying to get signed with a higher
level agency or an Asian at all since I
got here my manager did this I have a
wonderful manager named at Jason and he
made these contacts but i had to
accumulate enough of a body of work for
the agency to be interested in me then
it took a couple of months is set up the
meeting and then we actually did go and
meet it was very very different than
agent meetings I've been in before
because at that level things are quite
serious there's very little joviality
and there shouldn't be because it's a
big decision for both parties so and
it's been it's been good and it's been
different because now I'm represented by
someone who has some standing in the
industry so when people come for
projects that so they go to and my
manager in my agent have become sort of
a buffer which is hard in one way you
know it's hard because it is about
relationships but if you think of
yourself as a product then you know
there's always the middleman and those
who are representing the product and
putting on the shelf and that's that's
that's the best way to think of it what
can you tell some other actors about the
process and what some of the steps you
took and also to for maybe prior people
that wanted to sign you and you pull
back say no be willing to say no because
someone wants to sign you doesn't mean
that you should sign with them because
once you reach a level of doing 50 IBD
projects are people who say sure I'll
take you on but I've really depended on
my manager to say let's wait let's wait
let's wait until we can get with an
agency that means something and that's
hard to do it's really hard to wait
because again actors are needy
we just want to work we just want to
work we just want to work and that's all
that matters to us but from a business
standpoint there's more and it's the
power of saying no and it's it's the
hardest thing in the world for an actor
to say no
you